AHTATATATA(SKKRRAAAA)
Before this video begins, I have another exciting announcement!
(Haterz: Wowoww there's a lot of those Felix)
I have the Star Wars Titan Galactic Empire GPU, you like GPUs?
Of course you do!
I have also the Jedi version. So I'm doing a giveaway with Lirik and Origin PC
Where, it's worldwide so you can get one of these just by signing up in the link in the description!
Oh myy
...
Oh myyyyy
ಠ⌣ಠ
Origin PC also have a Black Friday sales right now, so if you're looking to buy a computer now
is a great time to do it before Christmas
Also the giveaway of
getting my computer is also available, so check out that as well.
(Haterz: Enough! Okay.. enough! I get it!)
Let's start the video!
HellooOoOO!
KonnichiwaAaAAa it Is PewDie-Sama In da hOuSe
Today, we're gonna review some memes that you've made are you excited?
Let's go do you like my hair?
I like it a lot, and I'm a little self-conscious about it, so please don't write any mean comments
Thank you. Who would, win some of the most respected news journals
Respected, Really? I don't think so.
some retarded swestian boi
I would probably win at who's the most seastian
(In Background:Felix: Edgar, What do you want?)
See I've been framed by the media guys, I keep telling you you haven't seen the full picture
I was just petting this innocent little dog it's like that that media
Image. there it is
It's like that one. You didn't see the full picture
I was just petting a dog an innocent dog. You should be thanking me giving me
Awards for being a good dog owner. Papa Frank of promoting PewDiePie glasses before it was mainstreamed
I'm that motherfucker took my glasses
Guess why this man quit soccer and how he is making billions and millions on
YouTube. We look nothing alike, my beard is at least 10 times better
Sorry whoever you are. When you have no ideas for a vid that is monetizeable
So you tell the stories on the internet yet you just read recently. I see here I am trying to make
Original content, and then it's just oh he just wants money
Then what can we pick on him about this time wait? Wait a minute? He's making original content
We needed a new excuse assholes. You're all assholes guys. Literally only want one thing and it's
effing disgusting Christian Channel fast internet damn boy for pink damn
damn, oh
But what's your upload? Huh? What's your upload?
This is downloading them all right PewDiePie giving his last brofist before ending the channel 20. How do you how would you even say that?
23:18
whatever
That's right. I will take on a sentient being I will become an AI in the form of shaggy from scooby-doo
Can you imagine my lifes brofist? Oh? That's right?
So you're filled with sad news now and not joy Felix Arvid Ulf Kjellberg artwork for PewDiePie shame will be appreciated Jesper
That's fuckin. Dope is this drawn or is it Photoshop? It looks sick man a very nice how-to handshake 101 shut the fuck up
Dammit, I don't ever want to see that shit again
Christian channel. Yeah, you know what that is how you
Pewdiepie reuploading you laugh you lose videos after YouTube takes them down
It's funny cuz it's true
Well Jeff play your effing. Thank you for censoring appreciate it Christian Channel alright. We're a swiss-tian reddit, so please
Haha, my name and just play them all play them all at once I fear no man, but that thing
It's good. That's just shit meme when you saw the new you laugh you lose when it was first uploaded, listen
I had I may have had a couple issues. Just a few issues on my last upload, but it wasn't my fault
I'm trying to provide quality
Family-friendly you know what I'm a nice guy, okay. I don't need to take this crap from you guys
Because I am NOT just
Family-friendly Felix I am nice guy
PewDiePie
Review fan work drink in the house, and tell Marzia. It's for me
You laugh you lose, Promote your shitty game you guys are just so kind
meme reviews
It's just behind the meme in disguise. No Anthony Fontana used to have a show called meme review
It was shut down because the fader wrote a slanderous article about him
And it was me I wrote the article so I can take over meme review its original content now
Because nothing else exists your move melon head
summary of this week's
You laugh, you lose try again. God dammit 2017 has just been a treat
I know everyone is trying to blame me for the ad pocalypse okay
I know you want a scapegoat. I know you want to point fingers. I'll use you fools. What are you complaining?
kids
What came first the egg or the chicken all right? I'm the egg blame the chicken
Please I didn't do nothing I'm nice guy PewDiePie family friendly swiss-tian  channel
I've improved and so can you please stop crying?
GAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
HAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
Haaaaaaaaa!!!!!!
haaa!!!
HAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
HAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
HAAAAAAAAA!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
HAA!!!
Very you get a to knit with two very nicest don't give out those very often one pewdiepie headset
99.99
77 copies of its everyday, bro by Jake Paul
99 33 wow the choice is obvious they both lead to cancer
So I guess you can't really go wrong. I would go with the bargain offer. Please. I'll have the 77 copies, please
Thank you there. It is. Can you stop can you stop? Can you? Thank you stop stop listen? I'm trying to promote a
Nice guy PewDiePie image. Okay. No more no more. No more of this. No more. Damn Marzia looks good.
I look good too, can you spot the difference?
99% impossible
holy shit. I can't tell them apart. I need to get one of those shinobi headbands
I think they're pretty cool. Trying out new games
Constantly trying and failing at one game, but it's all good because you can't die
And if you eventually beat it you can yell their death. Oh my god. It's true and get it. I'm gonna beat the game everyone
This is why I have trust issues Christian channel
Activated I don't believe in religion
No, no, I'm a Swiss-tian channel that I was just saying that prove a point guys
Please listen Swiss-tian channel forever for life any other
adjective very
Hey very nice meme
scout tada
Finola dude
My dad this translation is happened very nice
It's actually not perfectly correct grammar
But it's also very nice bike cuck my show got cancelled recently
I was pretty bummed out about it, but I think whoever cancelled
It was probably more happy to get it cancelled than I am sad to get it canceled what the heck
The total happiness in the world increased so whatever look at my cute little face so true
You know what suddenly? I don't even care that the show got canceled
It's not like it was the worst month of my life to produce that shitty show
But as long as the total happiness in the world was increased then I think it's okay
As long as everybody's happy
But I still got paid anyway
Students name the symbol. Oh my god. Oh
My god, that's good very nice
IKEA fucking shit
How did this get to the top page IKEA ea you can't get bad reviews?
If game journals can't get past the trattoria. It's pretty smart in
Inter and interent. I don't think you understand this meme
Loss you laugh you lose Christian channel original, okay fine fine. Haha you got you got a good one
Forty-year-old pewdiepie look it's me meme review
Meme review
That's it for this episode wait didn't I ask you to do the intro where the fuck are all my intros
I clearly have no control over this
This one one that's the winner oh, that's good, that's fuckin good Christian channel intro
Ah this is good too
Goddammit ah there's an animated one
Very nice ah man, so good terabrite may one cold school
Yeah boy
Hell yeah
Hey
New intro, 100% original content
Would say something mean, but I'm nice guy PewDiePie and that was a great intro well done very nice
I ran out of ideas. That's a good. That's a good title of it
That's a good anime by the way, you should watch it. Okay, well done well done on these intros
I can't believe I almost forgot it
next week just post the dankest meme you could find I
challenge you
brought squad fam and
Leave a like I would appreciate it see if we can get this on trending on YouTube if everyone liked the video
We'll probably get two million likes and if I get two million likes then finally that will
Motivate me to make some original content, so thank you appreciate it and as always
Laugh you lose
SKRATTAR DUUU